let me ask you um kind of a heavy
question for a physicist but one on
nuclear weapons
just in general what do you think about
nuclear weapons where like philosophical
level
where brilliant physicists and Brilliant
engineering leads to thing that can
destroy human civilization
so like some of the ideas
that you're working on
have power when it when engineered into
machines into systems is there some
aspects of you that worries I don't know
what the brilliant had to do with it
because of course
you know Oppenheimer and all that okay
they did it really fast but if you
didn't have Oppenheimer yeah you know I
mean would it all have happened anyway
it it's the it had a reality of its own
the possibility of making a nuclear
didn't it didn't depend on the fact that
the physicists who built it were
brilliant maybe that
bed it up by a year two years or but by
now we'd have nuclear weapons it's
something that so the ideas have
momentum and that they're um yeah
Unstoppable right the possibility of
making nuclear weapons was discovered
right it was there before
we didn't we didn't it's not like
somebody made it right
um
without Picasso
you know there would never have been a
Guernica but
without Oppenheimer that would surely
have still been
an atom bomb
but timing matters right timing is very
important there's a guy of course of
course of course
the timing matter the timing mattered
there
um
but I
I yeah
okay I mean you could try to make a case
for
stopping uh no no it's the case of
carrying the burden of the
responsibility of the power of ideas
when manifested through into systems so
there's not it's not a game it's not
just a game a fun mathematics the same
with artificial intelligence you have
this you know a lot of people in AI yeah
you know in a lot of people in the AI
Community it's a fascinating fun puzzle
how to make systems more and more
intelligent how to you have a bunch of
benchmarks you try to make them perform
better and better and better and all of
a sudden you have a system that's able
to all smart people
is now able to be used in geopolitics
it's able to create uh super intelligent
Bots that are able to at scale control
the belief of a population of people and
now you can have world wars you can have
a lot of really risky instabilities they
really are incredible and so to think
like there's some responsibility this is
not sort of
um
it's a beauty and a power and a a and a
terror to these ideas you know
yeah
at that moment it was certainly a
question for Oppenheimer and everybody
who participated in that what it what is
the responsible way to
serve Society
when you're
sort of accidentally in this position of
being at the Forefront of
a development that has a huge impact on
society I I don't see my work
the likelihood of having a huge impact
on the development of society itself but
if I were you
oh I love this working on AI yeah I
think that there is a possibility there
and that it is as a responsible
scientist that it's really not a good
thing to say I'm just the scientist here
and I'm figuring out what's possible
um because
you're in a role where you
you're you know you have more of a
a Podium to influence things than other
people and
it's your responsibility is it a citizen
of the planet or or let me phrase it a
little
less shouldy it's you know you have an
opportunity yeah
as a citizen of the planet to
make the world a better place which
which it would be sad too
to bypass yes a nice world without going
it'd be nice to keep it going for a
little bit longer